we've had an opportunity to meet with
an awful lot of consequential people
but i can say that
the ones who stand out in your mind
are those whose
relationship and interaction with you
are consistent with their reputation
when the queen had us to the castle for
tea and
we were joking crimpets
she kept offering me more i kept eating
everything she put in front of me
but
she was the same
uh in person as she as her image
decent honorable
and all about service
and uh
our hearts go out to the royal family
king charles and
all the family
it's a loss that leaves a giant hole
and
sometimes you think you'll never
you'll never overcome it
but
as i've told the king
she's going to be with him every step of
the way every minute every moment
and that's a reassuring notion
so to all the people of england all the
people united kingdom our hearts go out
to you and
you were fortunate to have had her for
70 years we all were the world's better
for her thank you mr president
just because the way she touched
when she leaned over the way uh
she had that look
like uh
are you okay anything i can do for you
what do you need and then also
make sure you do what you're supposed to
do what
[Music]
well i think
look um
the american press has heard me say for
a long time
but i think
the thing that is maybe it's too much
excuse the especially the irish of it
but
it's about treating people with dignity
i talk about how my mother
and father
thought that everyone no matter who they
were no matter what their station no
matter where they're from
deserved retreated with dignity
and that's exactly what she communicated
just the way she walked by her staff
just the way just the way she acted
and i think what she gave is a sense of
maybe above all
the notion of service
we all owe something
there's something within our capacity to
do
that can make things not not just the
world better but your neighborhood
better your household better
your workplace better
and that's what she communicated to me
anyway and i was an honor to meet her